in a special new issue the new york
times magazine is launching a series
called the 1619 project it marks the
400th anniversary of the arrival of the
first enslaved Africans in the colony of
Virginia the series examines the ways
the legacy of slavery continues to shape
this country the time says the project
aims to reframe American history and
place the consequences of slavery and
the contributions of black Americans at
the very center of the story we tell
ourselves about who we are the
journalists behind the project is New
York Times magazine domestic
correspondent Nicole Hannah Jones Nicole
good morning thanks for being here good
morning can you tell us about the
genesis of this project how do where did
you come up with the idea sure so I've
been thinking about the year 1619 since
I was in high school and I came across
that date in a book called before the
Mayflower and I just was struck by how
people of African descent had been here
that long and I never knew that data
never heard about it
so as the anniversary was approaching
the 400th year I thought that this was a
time to actually assess what does that
legacy been and to bring this year 1619
to most American households where it was
probably going to pass without them
knowing about a 1619 is as important as
1776 yes our decision to buy that first
group of twenty to thirty Africans would
influence almost everything that would
follow after I think it is foundational
it is as foundational to who we became
as a country as our decision in 1776 to
break off from the British you say black
Americans are the most American of all
and our true founding fathers can you
walk us through from that first ship to
today how we're still seeing the signs
yes so when you think about the fact
that when Thomas Jefferson is writing
the Declaration and laying out these
words for liberation that you know all
men are created equal and born with
inalienable rights and while he's
writing that he owns 130 human beings
who are an absolute bondage and in fact
his brother-in-law sitting there with
him enslaved to help keep him
comfortable what that means is those
ideals were not true when they were
written but black Americans took those
ideas literally and black Americans have
really fought you can look at what
happens after reconstruction you can
look at the abolitionist movement you
can look at the civil rights movement
people have fought to make those ideals
real perfecting democracy absolutely I
can just say this I was so embarrassed
as a person of color that I had never
heard of 1619 until I read your essay
page 16 when you first talked about it
and I just thought how do we not know
this and I'm not the only one there was
only one person there who bet to you
over there who went to Harvard she knew
about you and she knew all about this
project and knew all about the state but
you said it's time to stop hiding from
our sins and confront the truth what do
you mean what I mean is and how do we
not know about this Nicole we don't know
about 1619 the same way that we don't
learn very much about slavery it is
shameful no one wants to talk about
their sins or the worst moment and
slavery gives contradiction to our
entire creation story of the United
States and so we've tried to push it
aside we tried to make it marginal and
in doing that we've marginalized the 40
million descendants of the enslaved as
well so what we're trying to do with
this project is force us to confront the
truth and then maybe we can actually
start to to move past lavery and become
the country that was written in our
ideals in the Constitution and the
Declaration effort to reframe American
history but some critics have said it's
an effort to D legitimate American
history
from the Cato Institute ella shapiro
tweeted it's a project intended to
delegitimize mankind's grandest
experiment in human liberty is it
divisive in that way
I mean what's amazing about that is
people are not arguing the facts so what
they're basically arguing is that we
should only talk about certain facts we
should talk about the good part of
Thomas Jefferson but not about the fact
that he was in enslaver
I'm saying that history is history and
we have to tell the truth no it's not
the legitimacy because the whole point
of the argue of the article is that
black Americans have used those founding
words to actually bring us closer to the
democracy that the founders envisioned
and that is the most patriotic of things
you can take us the thing that's so
amazing about this that makes me so
proud
you can look about in anything that's
happening just about anything that's
happening in the world today and tie it
to slavery you look at the highways in
Atlanta you look at the naming of Wall
Street you look at sugar that we eat but
the thing that stuck out to me was
health care that you can type you can
tie health care to slavery how
absolutely so there's a piece in there
about why we're the only Western
industrialized
country that doesn't have universal
health care and it starts with
opposition to universal health care that
occurs right after slavery when the
Freedmen's Bureau was trying to offer
free health care to the formerly
enslaved and there was white opposition
to that and so even today you see with
polling that white Americans will reject
social programs if they think large
numbers of black people will benefit
from them and so the the harms of
slavery have not been contained because
there are millions of white Americans or
millions of Latinos and Asian and black
Americans who don't have health care who
can't get insurance because of slavery
you say don't look at black people as a
problem look at black people as a
solution
yes from the beginning there there have
been you know thousands of pages
dedicated to saying that black people
are as Abraham Lincoln said a
troublesome presence in our democracy
but really what we're arguing this
project as black Americans have been the
perfectors of this democracy and that if
we ever got to the point we were stopped
seeing us as a problem we would actually
be more of the America that we want to
be coal I stepped briefly on your line
earlier you you see this as a patriotic
act yes of course it is this isn't
saying that this is a country that needs
to be destroyed this is not saying that
this is a country that's illegitimate
it's saying that this was a country
founded on ideals that we're not true at
the time but the black Americans
believed in those ideals and have worked
to make those ideals true for all groups
I don't see what is more patriotic than
that well you couldn't have expected
this reaction which is huge by the way
congrats thank you so much and Bravo to
you tomorrow on CBS this morning our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
will take us to the site where the first
enslaved Africans arrived in English
North America and she will introduce us
to a family with a very special
connection to that historic period